ich finde ich wirklich ein schönes wort
benutzt du das auch aktiv manchmal wenn
die kinder nicht dabei sind weil die
verbieten mir dass er wieso verbieten
die kinder dass das ich versuche zu
reden haben ihr wissen
[Musik]
wörter die es nicht auf hochdeutsch ein
schönes buch mit ganz vielen wird dann
aus dem deutschen sprachraum die aus
irgendwelchen dialekten kommen toll
gemacht waren ganz viele wörter dabei
die ich wirklich noch nie gehört habe
und auch schon gerade wieder vergessen
im gegensatz zu philipp das testen wir
jetzt einfach mal hier
ja es hat irgendwas mit meinen das ist
dieser war der waren zuordnung star der
wahren trend ja oder zuordnung schreibt
macht doch genau so sind es sind schon
aber es heißt waren trennen starb okay
das scheinbar unbeabsichtigte vorzeigen
von statussymbolen deswegen hast du dir
das
daran bin ich ja ein meister ich möchte
übrigens an dieser stelle erwähnen dass
ich durchaus auch ein bisschen kritik an
diesem buch haben spielen sie zb kommen
zusammen mit heim lief heiß und das ist
nicht sehr sorgfältig recherchiert wird
das wird in diesem buch so dargestellt
als würde es sich um ein diskretes
verdecken von wohlstand handeln
in wahrheit ist heimliches mehr so was
wie schlitzohr
ich dachte er noch jemand der einfach
gerne die dinge heimlich machen ja also
es gibt je nach gegend auch verschiedene
auslegungen hast du's recherche ja
natürlich deshalb müsse sehr sorgfältig
speziellen aus dem secret vorbereitet
und nicola im übrigen bereite ich mich
immer auf unsere auftritte vor im
gegensatz zu gewissen anderen personen
die hier auch noch auf der bühne sitzen
und kein einziges wort aus diesem buch
kennen und damit meine ich dieses mal
okay sag mal 1a dabei die
allgegenwärtige personen auf jedem
fehler und verlagerte da steht auch drin
oder und verlagerte was ich auch sehr
schön findet dieses geheimnis und zwar
ist das quasi ans riechen gekoppelt man
riecht was und denkt
man ist wie in der zeitversetzt im ort
versetzt und das finde ich eine
wahnsinnig schönes erlebnis
kennst du ein wort was hier nicht
drinsteht was die auch was mir besonders
gut gefällt kommt aus dem
österreichischen ist zach gehört zach
ist schwer und mühsam ein wort an dem
alles klebt was irgendwie arbeit
bedeutet dann ist klar auch so schön
clever super dieser dünne und weißt du
woher das kommt von püree von weiler hat
so in den kaffee geweint dass es dünn
geworden ist das finde ich schön findest
du nicht auch dass diese arten von
seiner möglichen sammlung mit drolligen
illustrationen dass es immer auch ein
bisschen was kitschiges hatte weil das
ist ja sehr ausgewogen es hat
unterschiedliche regionen versammelt das
hat auch diesen so heimat verniedlichen
aspekt den ich schon ein bisschen
kitschig finden und ich will nur
irgendwas originelles noch zu diesem
buch sagen ich mach mal daran gewöhnen
schalten sie nächste woche wieder ein
wenn ich hier mit der echten nicolas
steiner sitzt nicht mit ihrer bösen
zwillingsschwester auf wiedersehen
[Musik]